here's a startling fact in the 45 years
since the introduction of the automated
teller machine those those vending
machines that dispense cash the number
of human bank tellers employed the
United States has roughly doubled from
about a quarter of a million to a half a
million or two million 1972 about half a
million today with a hundred thousand
added since the year 2000 these facts
revealed in a recent book by Boston
University economist James Besson raised
a intriguing question what are all those
tellers doing and why has an automation
eliminated their employment by now if
you think about it many of the great
inventions of the last 200 years were
designed to replace human labor tractors
were developed to substitute mechanical
power for human physical toil assembly
lines were engineered to replace
inconsistent human handiwork with
machine perfection computers were
programmed to swap out error-prone
inconsistent human calculation with
digital perfection these inventions have
worked
we no longer dig ditches by hand pound
tools out of wrought iron or do
bookkeeping using actual books and yet
the fraction of US adults employed in
the labor market is higher now in 2016
than it was 125 years ago in 1890 and
it's risen in just about every decade in
the intervening 125 years this poses the
paradox our machines increasingly do our
work for us why doesn't this make our
labor redundant and our skills obsolete
why are there still so many jobs
I'm going to try to answer that question
tonight and along the way I'm going to
tell you what this means for the future
of work and the challenges that
automation does and does not pose for
our society why are there so many jobs
there are actually two fundamental
economic principles at stake one has to
do with human genius and creativity the
other has to do with human insatiability
or greed if you like I'm going to call
the first of these the o-ring principle
and it determines the type of work that
we do the second principle is that never
get enough principle and it determines
how many jobs there actually are let's
start with the o-ring ATMs automated
teller machines had two countervailing
effects on bank teller employment as you
expect they replaced a lot of teller
tasks the number of tellers per branch
fell by about a third but as quickly
discovered it also was cheaper to open
new branches and the number of bank
branches increased by about 40% in the
same time period the net result was more
branches and more tellers but those
tellers were doing somewhat different
work as their routine cash handling
tasks receded they became less like
checkout clerks and more like
salespeople forging relationships with
customers solving problems and
introducing them to new products like
credit cards loans and investments more
tellers doing a more cognitively
demanding job there's a general
principle here most of the work that we
do requires a multiplicity of skills and
brains and brawn technical expertise and
intuitive mastery perspiration and
inspiration in the words of Thomas
Edison in general automating some subset
of those tasks doesn't make the other
ones unnecessary in fact it makes them
more important it increases their
economic value let me give you a stark
example in 1986 the space shuttle
Challenger exploded and crashed back
down to earth less than two minutes
after takeoff
the cause of that crash it turned out
was an inexpensive rubber o-ring in the
booster rocket that had frozen on the
launch pad the night before and failed
catastrophic ly moments after takeoff in
this multi-billion dollar enterprise
that simple rubber o-ring made the
difference between mission success and
the calamitous death of seven astronauts
an ingenious metaphor for this tragic
setting is the o-ring production
function named by Harvard economist
Michael Kramer after the Challenger
disaster the o-ring production function
conceives of the work as a series of
interlocking steps links in a chain
every one of those links must hold for
the mission to succeed if any of them
fails the the mission or the product or
the service comes crashing down this
precarious situation has a surprisingly
positive implication which is that
improvements in the reliability of any
one link in the chain increases the
value of improving any other links
concretely if most of the links are
brittle and prone to breakage the fact
that your link is not that reliable not
that important probably something else
will break anyway but as all the other
links become robust and reliable the
importance of your link becomes more
essential in the limit everything
depends upon it the reason the o-ring
was critical to space shuttle Challenger
is because everything else worked
perfectly if the Challenger were kind of
the space aero equivalent of Microsoft
Windows 2000
the reliability or ring wouldn't matter
because the machine would have crashed
here's the broader point in much of the
work that we do we are the o-rings yes
ATMs could do certain cash handling
tasks faster and better than tellers but
that can make teller superfluous it
increased the importance of their
province problem-solving skills and
their relationships with customers the
same principle applies if we're building
a building if we're diagnosing and
caring for a patient or if we are
teaching a class to a roomful of high
schoolers as tech not as our tools
improve technology magnifies our
leverage and increases the importance of
our expertise and our judgment and our
creativity and that brings me to the
second principle never get enough you
may be thinking okay or ring got it that
says the jobs that people do will be
important they can't be done by machines
but they still need to be done but that
doesn't tell me how many jobs they'll
need to be if you think about it isn't
it kind of self-evident that once we get
sufficiently productive of something we
basically worked our way out of a job in
1940 percent of all US employment was on
farms today it's less than 2% why are
there so few farmers today it's not
because we're eating less
a century of productivity growth in
farming means that now a couple of
million farmers can feed a nation of 320
million that's amazing progress but also
means there are only so many oring jobs
left in farming
so clearly technology can eliminate jobs
farming is only one example there are
many others like it but what's true
about a single product or service or
industry has never been true about the
economy the whole as a whole many of the
industries in which we now work health
and medicine finance and insurance
electronics and computing we're tiny or
barely existed a century ago many of the
products and we spend a lot of our money
on air conditioner sport utility
vehicles computers and mobile devices
were unattainable expensive or just
hadn't been invented a century ago as
automation frees our time increases the
scope of what is possible we invent new
products new ideas new services that
command our attention occupy our time
and spur consumption you may think some
of these things are frivolous extreme
yoga adventure tourism Pokemon go and I
might agree with you but people desire
these things and they're willing to work
hard for them the average worker in 2015
want to attain the average limit living
standard in 1915 could do so by working
just 17 weeks a year 1/3 of the time but
most people don't choose to do that they
were willing to work hard to harvest the
technological bounty that is available
to them material abundance has never
eliminated perceived scarcity in the
words of economist Thorstein Veblen
invention is the mother of necessity now
so if you accept these two principles
the o-ring principle and the never neck
get enough principle then you agree with
me there will be jobs does that mean
there's nothing to worry about
Automation and employment robots and
jobs it'll all take care of itself no
that is not my argument Automation
creates wealth by
allowing us to do more work in less time
there's no economic law that says that
we will use our that wealth well and
that is worth worrying about consider
two countries Norway and Saudi Arabia
both oil-rich nations it's like they
have money spurting out of a hole in the
ground but they haven't used that wealth
equally well to foster human prosperity
human prospering Norway is a thriving
democracy by and large its citizens work
and play well together it's typically
numbered between 1st and 4th and
rankings of national happiness Saudi
Arabia is an absolute monarchy which in
which many citizens lack a path for
personal advancement it's typically
ranked 35th among nations and Happiness
which is low for such a wealthy nation
just by way of comparison the u.s. is
typically ranked around 12th or 13th the
difference between these two countries
is not their wealth and it's not their
technology it's their institutions
Norway has invested to build a society
with opportunity and economic mobility
Saudi Arabia has raised living standards
while frustrating many other human
strivings two countries both wealthy not
equally well-off and this brings me to
the challenge that we face today the
challenge that automation poses for us
the challenge is not that we're running
out of work the US has added 14 million
jobs since the depths of the Great
Recession
the challenge is that many of those jobs
are not good jobs and many citizens
cannot qualify for the good jobs that
are being created employment growth in
the United States and in much of the
developed world looks something like a
barbell with increasing poundage on
either end of the bar on the one hand
you have high education high wage jobs
like doctors and nurses programmers and
engineers marketing and sales managers
employment is robust in these jobs
employment growth
similarly employment growth is robust in
many low skill low education jobs like
food service cleaning security
home health aides simultaneously
employment is shrinking in many middle
education middle wage middle-class jobs
like blue-collar production and
operative positions and white-collar
clerical and sales position the reasons
behind this contracting middle are not
mysterious many of those middle skill
jobs use well understood rules and
procedures that can increasingly be
codified in software and execute
executed by computers the challenge that
this phenomenon crave creates what
economists call employment polarization
is that it knocks out rungs in the
economic ladder shrinks the size of the
middle class and threatens to make us a
more stratified society on the one hand
a set of highly paid highly educated
professionals doing interesting work on
the other a large number of citizens in
low paid jobs whose primary
responsibility is to see to the comfort
and health of the affluent that is not
my vision of progress and I doubt that
it's yours but here are some encouraging
news we have faced equally momentous
economic transformations in the past and
we have come through them successfully
in the earth in the late 1800s and early
1900s when automation was eliminating
vast numbers of agricultural jobs
remember that tractor the farm states
faced a threat of mass unemployment a
generation of youth no longer needed on
the farm but not prepared for industry
rise into this challenge they took the
radical step of requiring that their
entire youth population remain in school
and continue their education to the ripe
old age of 16 this was called the high
school movement and it was a radically
expensive thing to do not only did they
have to invest in the schools but those
kids couldn't work at their jobs it also
turned out to be one of the best
investments the u.s. made in the 20th
century it gave us the most skilled the
most flexible and the most productive
workforce in the world to see how well
this worked imagine taking the labor
force of 1899 and bringing them into the
present
despite their strong
Bax and good characters many of them
would lack the basic literacy and
numeracy skills to do all but the most
mundane jobs many of them would be
unemployable what this example
highlights is the primacy of our
institutions most especially our schools
and allowing us to reap the harvest of
our technological prosperity it's
foolish to say there's nothing to worry
about clearly we can get this wrong if
the US had not invested in schools and
in its skills a century ago with a high
school of movement we would be a less
prosperous a less mobile and probably a
lot less happy society but it's equally
foolish to say that our faiths are
sealed
that's not decided by the machines it's
not even decided by the market it's
decided by us and by our institutions
now I started this talk for the paradox
our machines increasingly do our work
for us why does that make our labor
superfluous our skills redundant isn't
it obvious that the road to our economic
and social hell is paved with our own
great inventions history has repeatedly
offered an answer to that paradox the
first part of the answer is that
technology magnifies our leverage
increases the importance the add value
of our expertise our judgment and our
creativity that's the o-ring the second
part of the answer is our endless
inventiveness and bottomless desires
means that we never get enough never get
enough there's always new work to do
adjusting to the rapid pace of
technological change creates real
challenges seen most clearly in our
polarized labor market and the threat
that it poses to economic mobility
rising to this challenge is not
automatic it's not costless it's not
easy but it is feasible and here are
some encouraging news because of our
amazing productivity we're rich of
course we can afford to invest in
ourselves and in our children as America
did 100 years ago with a high school
movement arguably we can't afford not to
now you may be thinking professor otter
has told us a heartwarming tale about
the distant past the recent past
maybe the present but
probably not the future because
everybody knows that this time is
different right is this time different
of course this time is different every
time is different a numerous occasions
in the last 200 years scholars and
activists have raised the alarm that we
are running out of work and making
ourselves obsolete
for example the Luddites in the early
1800s US Secretary of Labor James Davis
in the mid 1920s Nobel prize-winning
economists Vasily leontyev in 1982 and
of course many scholars pundits
technologists and media figures today
these predictions strike me as arrogant
these self-proclaimed Oracle's are in
effect saying if I can't think of the
few of what people will do for work in
the future than you me and our kids
aren't going to think of it either I
don't have the guts to take that bet
against human ingenuity look I can't
tell you what people are going to do for
work a hundred years from now but the
future doesn't hinge on my imagination
if I were a farmer in Iowa in the year
1900 an economist from the 21st century
teleported down to my field and said hey
guess what farmer otter in the next
hundred years
agricultural employment is going to fall
from 40% of all jobs to 2% purely due to
rising productivity what do you think
the other 38% of workers are going to do
I would not have said oh we got this the
do app development radiological medicine
yoga instruction bitmoji
I wouldn't have had a clue but I hope I
would have had the wisdom to say Wow
a 95 percent reduction in farm
employment with no shortage of food
that's an amazing amount of progress I'd
hope if humanity finds something
remarkable to do with all of that
prosperity and by and large I would say
that it has thank you very much